you can't get enough of The Witcher
Netflix series then we've got some good
news for you turn on your PC apply a few
months startup The Witcher 3 and boom
you can relive the look and feel of the
show with the storyline of Witcher 3
with these 8 PC mods you'll be able to
find the links to all these mods in the
description below
first things first let's start with the
main menu you can switch out the main
menu music with the Netflix theme song
it'll be the perfect way to start your
game off with some of those live-action
vibes and while we're on the subject of
music then you already know you want
tossa coins here witcher in your games
[Music]
now that you've got it stuck in your
head you might as well add it to your
soundtrack then have those lovely street
performers serenade you as you walk
through town
and for those of you with your witcher 1
copies on deck here's a bonus mod you
can even add a charming little cutscene
with dandelion Singh in our favorite
tune
[Music]
you know what while you're at it just go
ahead and add the entire Netflix
soundtrack to your game just keep in
mind that the in-game music will be
completely replaced and not just added
on to unnecessary sacrifice if you ask
me now that we have those sweet sweet
melodies in order let's get to some
visuals girlthe is getting a glow up
this mod is the closest we'll get to
having Henry Cavill himself in CD
Projekt breads masterpiece the eyes the
bone structure the chin it's all there
and it's all on point and in case you
missed it we have a full let's play with
this gorgeous mod on our channel right
now
[Music]
go before for even more added detail you
can add the toxic black eyes to grow up
from the Netflix series that works in
tandem with your in-game toxicity levels
and now that we're done with that
beautiful face go ahead and give her
I'll be head to toe look you can mod
those Netflix threads into the game and
equip girl with his live action armor
set how about I buy everybody around why
would you got the coin for it simple as
that
up next is the agnolotti re-texture to
make yennefer resemble her live-action
counterpart from the jaw line to the
deep purple eyes it's pretty darn close
just make sure you follow the
installation instructions to the letter
though because you will end up with some
hilariously glitchy cutscenes throughout
the game if you don't and when it comes
to finding the right actor or actress
for the role not every detail will align
perfectly with lore this mod changes
series emerald green eyes to the
beautiful icy blue of Freya Allen's from
the series a small but nice touch to
round out your Netflix mods more and
more mods are being made every day for
The Witcher 3 and although we rounded up
as many as we could that were related to
the Netflix series there are sure to be
new ones in the future if this video
helped you make your game more like the
show then leave us a like and also be
sure to check out our a correct way to
play Witcher 3 guide on our channel made
by our in-house Witcher expert Jake
Dekker but of course not before you toss
the coin to your Witcher